damen und herren unsere heutigen
gespräche mit der bundeskanzlerin waren
sehr konstruktiv wie eigentlich immer
wir haben sehr ausführlich gesprochen
unter anderem unter teilnahme der
anderen delegationsmitglieder gesprochen
über die zukunft der bilateralen
beziehungen zwischen russland und
deutschland
wir haben eine reihe von fragen
besprochen
eine besondere rolle
spielt natürlich der bevorstehende
wahlkampf die wahl im september
die bundeskanzlerin wird nicht erneut
antreten wir werden aber natürlich immer
auch in zukunft sehr froh sein die
bundeskanzlerin in russland empfangen zu
dürfen
wir haben sehr großen respekt vor ihrer
leistung die sie über 16 jahre gebracht
hat sie ist an der spitze einen der
größten länder
wirtschaftsstärksten länder und sie ist
auch eine der wichtigsten politischen
persönlichkeiten auf der internationalen
bühne wir haben sehr lange miteinander
gearbeitet und somit entspringen den
zahlreichen treffen auch sehr enge
beziehungen wir haben über unsere
bilateralen beziehungen gesprochen wir
haben versucht uns abzustimmen zu den
internationalen politischen fragen
natürlich das muss man sagen waren wir
uns nicht immer einig doch wir haben
immer einen offenen
inhaltsreichen dialog geführt wir waren
immer auf der suche nach einem
kompromiss egal für welchen
herausforderungen wir standen ich möchte
betonen dass deutschland eine der
zentralen partner für russland ist
sowohl in der politik wie auch in der
wirtschaft auch unsere wirtschaftlichen
handelsbeziehungen sind zentral und
beachtet der globalen pandemie diese ist
und bleibt
sehr große herausforderung dennoch
konnten wir unsere beziehungen
fortführung unser handelsvolumen wächst
erneut
etwa 33 prozent steigerung
haben wir dieses jahr gesehen etwa 21
milliarden euro
beträgt er rund 30 milliarden empfang
erwarten hier insgesamt
im moment findet dass deutschland ja in
russland statt gewidmet ist sind dieses
jahr der und förderung der
wirtschaftsbeziehungen noch ein problem
der allgemeinen entwicklung wir sprechen
in dem rahmen über eine ganze reihe
gemeinsamer projekte im bereich handel
agrarwirtschaft und entwicklung
wir haben auch zahlreiche
umfassende projekte diese sind allen
bekannt sie laufen auch weiterhin
hervorragend und wir hoffen natürlich
dass es nicht das letzte projekt bleibt
wir haben eine reihe von dezentralen
international politischen fragen
tangiert wir haben natürlich über die
lage in afghanistan gesprochen das ist
eine der wichtigsten fragen heute
gewesen die besprochen wurden
die machtübernahme der taliban über fast
das gesamte land ist da besser dran die
realität und davon müssen wir leider
ausgehen muss
wir dürfen nicht zulassen dass die
afghanische regierung zerfällt wir
müssen die
verantwortungslose politik nun
verantworten wir müssen natürlich dazu
beitragen dass sie mein ende gelegt wird
wir müssen die demokratie aufbauen und
stärken
es kann nicht sein dass
die demokratie anderen bewegungen zum
opfer fällt und auch andere lebensformen
müssen akzeptiert werden wir kennen
afghanistan und zwar sehr gut schweizer
kunden persönlich erleben wie dieses
land aufgebaut ist und das ist
kontraproduktiv ist diesem land etwas
aufzuzwingen sei es was die politische
fragen oder auch die gesellschaftlichen
fragen anbelangt solche politischen
bestrebungen habe noch nie zu einem
erfolg geführt ganz im gegenteil soziale
politische systeme wurden degradiert wir
haben ganz im gegenteil sogar gesehen
dass die pal taliban bereits zur
rechtsordnung schaffung übergegangen
sind
es gibt internationale missionen die
weiterhin laufen und wir hoffen dass
unsere pläne dort
auch weiter fortgeführt werden wir
hoffen dass die internationale
gemeinschaft da zusammenhält und wir
hoffen natürlich auf ihre unterstützung
des un-sicherheitsrates außerdem ist es
von zentraler bedeutung
die ausdehnung der machtübernahme nicht
zuzulassen die taliban dürfe nicht über
die grenzen des landes hinweg schreiten
wir haben dahingehend natürlich die
beilegung der regionale probleme
besprochen wir haben natürlich aber auch
über die krise in der ost ukraine
gesprochen und wir haben alle gemeinsam
nach einer lösung gesucht um die bambas
frage zu lösen leider haben wir es
bisher nicht geschafft
heute hat sowohl die russische wie auch
die deutsche seite ihre besorgnis
geäußert jeweils was die neuesten
entwicklungen anbelangt und ich hoffe
dass wir diese gespräche auch in zukunft
fortführen leider wurden etwa
1000 fälle der nicht einhaltung der
waffenruhe in dombach festgestellt das
kann natürlich eine nicht unruhig lassen
wir haben eine reihe von gesetzen
beschlossen
und beziehungsweise es wurden in der
ukraine
gesetze verabschiedet die gegen das
minsker abkommen
gerichtet sind
dahingehend wenden wir uns nun erneut an
die frau bundeskanzlerin
auf die ukrainische regierung einfluss
zu nehmen denn es steht ja ein besuch in
der ukraine bevor
sei es verständlich sprachen wir auch
wer die lage in belarus und auch das
haben wir umfassend besprochen
des weiteren möchte ich betonen dass es
durchaus gegensätzliche bewegungen gibt
eben rahmen des landes selbst in belarus
selbst gibt es gegenseitige kräfte wir
hoffen dass eine einigung erzielt werden
kann ohne eine internationale
einmischung wir haben beide die hoffnung
dass nach dem eine neue regierung im
iran installiert wurde unsere bemühungen
zur
gemeinsam handlungsplan dass diese
bemühungen weiterhin bestehen bleiben
es stehen auch telefongespräche mit dem
neuen iranischen präsidenten bevor
im januar des vergangenen jahres
habe ich auch
an der berliner konferenz diese wurde
von der bundeskanzlerin organisiert und
unsere bemühungen haben zu einer
verbesserung der internationalen lage
und beigetragen und wir sind der meinung
dass auch weiterhin der internationale
dialog fortgeführt werden muss
die positiven entwicklungen
voranzutreiben
international die wir bis jetzt noch
nicht so ganz erreicht haben noch sind
wir nicht am ziel wir sehen da aber
positive impulse
syrien wird die waffenruhe größtenteils
er respektiert im moment läuft der
aufbau der infrastruktur
jedoch gibt es auch dort eine bedrohung
durch die terroristischen gruppierungen
vor ort und auch da spielt natürlich die
korona pandemie eine sehr zentrale rolle
im juli wurde
eine neue resolution beschlossen von der
un das ist in vielen
summit geschuldet der in genf
stattgefunden hat und zwischen unter
anderem der usa und russland und da sind
wir sehr froh dass es zu dieser
revolution gekommen ist so wird das
syrische volk umfassender unterstützt
ich möchte mich erneut bei der frau
bundeskanzlerin bedanken für die
fruchtbare zusammenarbeit in all den 16
jahren die sie im amt war ich möchte
noch mal betont wir sind stets froh die
bundeskanzlerin in moskau empfangen zu
dürfen vielen dank
danke schön dass ihr geehrter herr
präsident lieber bleibt die mir meine
damen und herren ich
habe heute zu beginn meines besuchs
einen kranz niedergelegt am grabmal des
unbekannten soldaten und damit noch
einmal daran gedacht das vor 80 jahren
hitler deutschland die sowjetunion
überfallen hat und ich bin bei allen
meinungsverschiedenheiten die wir heute
haben zwischen russland und der
deutschen regierung sehr sehr froh dass
wir miteinander reden und der heutige
besuch galt genau dem und es war ein
konstruktives gespräch ein gespräch das
differenzen aufgezeigt hat aber auch
ansätze für gemeinsame lösungen die wir
finden wollen was unsere bilateralen
beziehungen anbelangt so haben sie genau
diesen charakter dass es dinge gibt die
sehr positiv hervorzuheben sind ich
möchte hier die wirtschaftlichen
beziehungen nennen möchte das
deutschlandjahr nennen das vom
russischen präsidenten auch schon
erwähnt wurde in dem es viele viele
begegnungen von menschen gibt und auch
die initiative der wirtschaft mit dem
projekt 1000 praktiker die 1000 jungen
russinnen und russen die möglichkeit
gibt bei deutschen firmen ein praktikum
zu machen das sind beziehungen die aus
meiner sicht sehr erfreulich sind aber
wir haben natürlich auch über die
bedrückende situation von alexei navalny
gesprochen aus unserer perspektive ist
dass die verurteilung zum aufenthalt in
einer strafkolonie auf der grundlage
eines früheren urteils dass der
europäische gerichtshof für
menschenrechte er für und offenkundig
unverhältnismäßig
klassifiziert hat nicht akzeptabel und
ich habe gegenüber dem russischen
präsidenten noch einmal die freilassung
von alexei navalny
gefordert und auch deutlich gemacht dass
wir hier an der sache dranbleiben werden
und ich habe darüber gesprochen dass wir
sehr enttäuscht sind dass drei deutsche
nichtregierungsorganisationen
gelistet wurden die im petersburger
dialog
substanziell zu der verbesserung und
intensivierung
deutsch-russischer
zivilgesellschaft prozesse beigetragen
haben und darum dringend gebeten ob wir
diese klassifizierung aufheben könnten
um die weitere arbeit des petersburger
dialogs möglich zu machen aus meiner
sicht wäre das ein sehr wichtiges
zeichen wir haben über bilaterale
wirtschaftsbeziehungen gesprochen die
sich auch ansonsten recht gut entwickeln
und natürlich in dem zusammenhang auch
über das projekt in austin zwei dass ich
deutlich machen möchte noch einmal kein
bieler traf deutsch-russisches projekt
ist sondern ein projekt mit europäischen
charakter jedenfalls ist eine vielzahl
von firmen aus anderen ländern hier auch
dabei in diesem zusammenhang haben wir
natürlich über die frage der des papiers
zwischen der bundesrepublik deutschland
und den vereinigten staaten von amerika
gesprochen und wir haben mit dem
russischen präsidenten darüber geredet
dass wir mit graf waldersee einen
erfahrenen verhandler noch einmal
benannt haben um darüber zu sprechen
dass auch der transit vertrag für die
ukraine über das jahr 2022 hinaus
verlängert werden kann und soll und dass
wir uns hierfür auch verantwortlich
fühlen bei allen wirtschaftlichen
grundlagen geht dabei natürlich auch zu
beachten sind in dem zusammenhang haben
wir auch über die beziehungen der
europäischen union und russland geredet
ist es von russischer seite gerade noch
einmal deutlich gemacht worden dass im
zusammenhang mit dem paket für fit for
flash fdt 3.5 also dem klimapaket
gerade im blick auf die grenz ausgleich
steuern und viele andere probleme ein
hohes russisches interesse besteht hier
in einen austausch mit der europäischen
union einzutreten und ich habe auch
zugesagt dass ich mich dafür einsetzen
werde
aktuell war natürlich das thema
afghanistan für uns von besonderer
wichtigkeit wir haben uns hier zu
ausgetauscht ich habe deutlich gemacht
dass natürlich ist ein
sehr
frustrierender moment ist zu erleben
dass die taliban zurückgekehrt sind und
das land kontrollieren aber es gehört
auch zur realistischen einschätzung dass
es so ist wie ich habe darüber
informiert dass wir uns aus deutscher
perspektive im augenblick vorrang hat
menschen die für deutschland in den 20
jahren des militäreinsatzes der nato
gearbeitet haben afghanische bürger eine
sichere einen sicheren aufenthalt in
deutschland bekommen sollen und dass wir
alles daran setzen in den nächsten tagen
möglichst viele von diesen menschen noch
nach deutschland zu bringen und ich habe
auch darum gebeten dass russland in den
gesprächen mit den taliban darauf
hinweist dass eine zusammenarbeit auch
in humanitären fragen mit den taliban
auch mit un organisationen in
afghanistan
dann besser möglich ist wenn natürlich
auf der anderen seite auch aus unserer
perspektive die menschen die uns
geholfen haben in den jahren der
bundeswehr der bundespolizei den
entwicklungsorganisationen geholfen
haben eine möglichkeit bekommen das land
zu verlassen wir haben über die
situation mit der ukraine gesprochen das
nochmal die format ist das einzige
politische format das wir zur verfügung
haben um die streitthemen
miteinander zu diskutieren
es ist hier eine stagnation im
augenblick eingetreten leider sterben
immer wieder auch ukrainische soldaten
an der kontakt linie und ich habe mich
sehr dafür eingesetzt alles daran zu
setzen eine belebung zu erreichen das
letzte treffen auf der ebene der staats
und regierungschefs war im dezember
2009 10 in paris und die vorhaben die
wir uns in paris vorgenommen haben sind
wieder von der seite der
[Musik]
separatisten den ökologisch noch von der
ukraine auf der anderen seite umgesetzt
wurden und ich habe jedenfalls meine
bereitschaft deutlich gemacht der
russische präsident hat dass sie eben
auch gesagt dass wir noch mal versuchen
in den nächsten wochen hier
voranzukommen
um wirklich die interessen der menschen
in der ukraine und das glaube ich gilt
für alle in einem zu einem friedlichen
leben auch deutlich machen können dass
wir an unserer haltung dass die
kollektion der krim eine verletzung der
territorialen integrität der ukraine ist
dass wir bei dieser haltung bleiben
versteht sich von selbst und ich werde
mich jedenfalls bis zum letzten amtstag
dafür einsetzen dass die territoriale
integrität der ukraine gewährleistet
sein kann ich habe im zusammenhang mit
dem bus darauf hingewiesen dass ich aufs
schärfste verurteile menschen
flüchtlinge
menschen aus anderen ländern die in not
sind sozusagen als hybride waffe
einzusetzen
im blick auf die weiße bilder russisch
litauisch grenze und wir haben natürlich
über die themen libyen syrien und
zügigen gesprochen gerade bezüglich
libyen wäre es gut wenn wir uns zur
umsetzung auch der berliner konferenzen
es schaffen würden reziprok also
proportional die
ausländischen söldner aus libyen
abzuziehen um die möglichkeit den
typischen kräften zu geben ihre pläne
und ihre vorstellungen über die zukunft
libyens auch selbst zu lösen hier gibt
es eine ganze reihe von
übereinstimmungen zwischen russland und
deutschland und wir werden uns auf
diesem feld auch weiter engagieren wir
haben natürlich auch über die
herausforderung des klimawandels
gesprochen russland und deutschland sind
beide von schweren naturkatastrophen
heimgesucht russland in ganz besonderer
weise im sibirischen bereich im jenseits
des polarkreises wir verfolgen dass
diese schrecklichen herausforderungen
auch für die menschen und wir sind
deshalb überzeugt dass wir für den
klima- oder für den kampf gegen den
klimawandel
natürlich auch eng zusammenarbeiten
sollten und müssen und das gilt
natürlich auch für andere internationale
fragen aber ich möchte sagen dass ich in
den jahren ich glaube ich war 16 mal in
russland in 16 jahren also habe
regelmäßig die kontakte gesucht waren
nicht immer einfacher gespräche oft sehr
kontroverse gespräche auch auf der
internationalen bühne aber es war der
versuch kompromisse zu finden und ich
glaube es gibt im internationalen
kontext keine alternative dazu keine
vernünftige keine vernünftige
alternative als zu versuchen zu reden
argumente auszutauschen und immer wieder
auch dicke bretter dabei zu bohren es
könnte einfacher sein sicherlich aber
das reden sollte weitergehen dass davon
bin ich ganz überzeugt herzlichen dank
es ist die vision des bildungsgipfel
bürger so wird proteine und kollegen sie
haben nun die möglichkeit von jeder
seite jeweils zwei fragen zu stellen
bitteschön unsere gäste haben das wort
die deutsche seite mit friedrich schmidt
von der frankfurter allgemeinen zeitung
herzlichen dank
frau bundeskanzlerin sie haben ja gesagt
dass sie sich heute auch wieder
eingesetzt haben für die nacht ihren
russischen oppositionsführer alexej
nawalny freizulassen deshalb ein sie
präsident putin die frage was braucht es
um herrn aber allen die freizulassen und
was braucht es damit die verfolgung von
herrn alleiniges unterstützern in
russland aufhört und an sie beide die
frage einer weile hat heute aus anlass
des ersten jahrestages seiner vergiftung
in mehreren zeitungen darunter auch in
meiner einen gastbeitrag veröffentlicht
in dem er fordert den kampf gegen
korruption als wurzel vieler übel ganz
oben auf die weltweite themen agenda zu
setzen
was braucht das was halten sie von
diesem vorschlag und was halten sie ihr
habt dass ihr dann tut ihnen davon dass
ja panik fordert sanktionen auch gegen
kollegen aus ihrem umfeld zu verhängen
ich möchte betonen dass er nicht für
seine politische handlungen verurteilt
wurde sondern er hat gewisse regeln
verletzt diese gelten unter anderem
unsere internationalen da was seine
politische aktivität anbelangt so sollte
niemand so sich hinter politischen
maßnahmen verstecken sondern dazu stehen
was er eigentlich möchte was die
opposition insgesamt anbelangt so würde
ich gerne folgendes sagen ich sehe
ehrlich gesagt nicht dass im westen in
europa oder in den usa
wir können da zum beispiel war occupy
wall street sprechen aber andere
ähnliche bewegungen ich kann mich nicht
daran erinnern dass diese von den
jeweiligen regierungen besondere
unterstützung erfahren haben so etwas
haben wir nicht gesehen
darüber hinaus wenn wir über den sturm
auf dem kongress in den usa
sprechen
so
wurden wurde gegen sie strafanzeige auf
höchster ebene
erstattet ihnen drohen gefängnisstrafen
von
15 20 über 25 jahre vielleicht sogar
länger deswegen würde ich sie nun gerne
um eine gewisse objektivität bitten
deswegen schauen sie sich das doch bitte
auch im internationalen rahmen
was uns jedoch anbetrifft so möchte ich
sagen dass unser politisches system sich
in einer entwicklung befindet alle
unsere staatsbürger haben das recht ihre
meinung kundzutun auch zur politischen
fragen
sie können politische organisationen
aufbauen sie können an wahlen teilnehmen
auf allen ebenen aber das muss man im
gesetzlichen konstitutionellen rahmen
tun wir werden alles dafür tun um die
situation in russland stabil zu halten
vorausschau ba
man muss sagen seinen bedarf an
revolutionen hat russland erschöpft
bereits im zwanzigsten jahrhundert wir
möchten nach vorne schauen wir möchten
eine entwicklung unserer gesellschaft
sehen und wir hoffen darauf dass es auch
so eintreten wird
was die gerichte und deren
entscheidungen anbelangt so möchte ich
folgendes sagen
bitte respektieren sie diese
was den kampf gegen die korruption
anbelangt dass es natürlich eine sehr
zentrale frage aber das sollte kein
politisches instrument sein das soll
nicht missbraucht werden als argument
und das wissen sie sehr wohl dass dieses
instrument sehr gerne benutzt wird und
auch empfunden wird durchaus
gewisse politische ziele zu erreichen
das machen viele organisationen
die hinter solchen menschen stehen der
eigentliche kampf gegen die korruption
ist tatsächlich zentral dem messen wir
die größte bedeutung bei und wir werden
auch weiterhin alles dafür tun um die
korruption auszumerzen im aller
weitesten sinne dieses wortes
haben recht ausführlich über unsere
auffassung über politische systeme und
über die freiheit politischer betätigung
gesprochen ich glaube auch dass die
frage eines
guten politischen systems und die
korruptionsbekämpfung sehr wohl
miteinander verbunden sind zu der
forderung von alexei navalny dass man
diese aktionen aushalten sollte wirklich
nur noch einmal darauf hinweisen dass
sanktionen heute
der europäischen union daran geknüpft
sind dass ein unmittelbarer zusammenhang
zwischen dem sanktionierten und dem
sachverhalt ist das heißt also dass es
hier nicht ganz so einfach die brücke zu
schlagen von wirtschaftlicher korruption
zu
sanktionierungen aber wir haben auch in
der europäischen union schon darüber
gesprochen dass wir über diese fragen
noch einmal sprechen wollen weil eben
korruption und politisches handeln nicht
so ein cockpit sind sondern durchaus aus
meiner sicht das gilt auch für
deutschland wo immer produktion auftritt
sehr sehr eng zusammenhängen und dafür
braucht man eben auch gerade eine
unabhängige justiz eine unabhängige
presse und sind eben auch manchmal
unbequeme
nichtregierungsorganisationen weil
selten aus dem regierungs tun selbst die
dinge von selbst vollkommen sozusagen
bekämpft werden die schlicht
den kampf gegen die korruption sollten
menschen führen die sich selbst an dass
gesundheitliche rufen das ist vielleicht
eine der wichtigsten bedingungen die in
diesem rahmen will grunde liegen um ihn
auch gewinnen zu können
nächste frage bitte
guten tag dimitris
ich würde gerne eine frage zum
afghanistan lage sprechen sie bewerten
sie das ergebnis des 20-jährigen
einsatzes des besseres kann man ihn als
gescheitert betrachtet und ist es für
sie ein grund
die herangehensweise an diese fragen zu
ändern und auch die einmischung von
drittländern neu einzuschätzen eine
bitte auch an frau bundeskanzlerin sie
sind wahrscheinlich im bilde darin über
das im moment
auf deutsch gerne senden möchte jedoch
werden werden wir blockiert durch die
deutsche regierung
man muss auch sagen und das den
deutschen banken empfohlen worden ist
alle konten zu sperren die damit
irgendwie in verbindung stehen das ist
eine sehr offene
information sich offen zugänglich
momentan ist eben auch deutsche mächte
einfluss auf luxemburgische mächte in
diesem
bereich frau bundeskanzlerin bitte
helfen sie uns doch bei unserer
meinungsfreiheit lassen sie mich bitte
kurz darauf zu sprechen kommt man kann
den einsatz in afghanistan natürlich
nicht als erfolgreich bezeichnen aber
wir sollten da nicht auf der stelle
treten und auch kein salz in die wunde
streuen
und darüber sprechen als wäre das ein
komplettes versagen denn wir sind
schließlich daran interessiert dass das
land wieder zu seiner stabilität oder zu
einer stabilität findet
ich glaube dass viele westliche
politiker
nun begreifen was ich auch bereits
gesagt habe eingangs dass man niemandem
von außen die eigenen politischen
standards aufzwingen kann es sind andere
länder andere sitten andere völker
es geht da auch um ethnische religiöse
fragen
historische traditionen ich glaube dass
dieses bewusstsein wirklich sagen muss
und
auch die grundlage liefern muss für
zukünftiges handeln
wir waren zeuge
was im rahmen des arabischen frühlings
geschehen ist
wir müssen aber auch sichergehen dass
alle unsere partner
einheitlich das einheiten und zwar
respekt zollen den jeweiligen partnern
man sollte auch
geduld haben ganz unabhängig davon was
einem gefällt was einem nicht zu sagt
denn jedes land hat schließlich das
eigene schicksal in der hand
sie haben den demokratischen weg
eingeschlagen ganz unabhängig davon wie
lange sie auf diesem weg nun sind
diese entwicklung hat uns gefallen hat
uns zugesagt jedoch müssen wir nun da
die beziehungen reparieren und versuchen
international damit zurechtzukommen und
den konflikt möglichst beizulegen wir
werden mit unseren partnern mit den usa
mit europäischen ländern werden wir also
russland alles dafür tun
unsere bemühungen zu vereinen um das
afghanische volk zu unterstützen um die
lage beizulegen
und wir müssen da
eine gute grundlage schaffen
das will ich noch mal an den
ausgangspunkt erinnern es gab die
anschläge die sich jetzt ja auch zum
zwanzigsten mal jähren am 11 september
2001 und damals sind aus afghanistan
terroristische angriffe auf die
vereinigten staaten von amerika
durchgeführt wurden das hat dazu geführt
dass im kampf gegen den terrorismus dann
auch der nato einsatz
abgestimmt wurde durchgeführt wurde die
gefahr des akuten terrorismus ist
vielleicht im augenblick in afghanistan
einigermaßen gewandt hat sich die lage
verbessert gegenüber 2001 aber sie ist
nicht dauerhaft gebannt deshalb sind wir
uns auch auf jeden fall eigentlich
internationale staatengemeinschaft gegen
das widerstehen des terrorismus aus
afghanistan heraus einzutreten aber in
einem anderen projekt nämlich dass es
eine gemeinschaftliche haltung der
afghanischen bevölkerung zu für ihre
eigene zukunft gibt haben wir nicht
unsere ziele erreicht das will ich ganz
offen sagen ich erinnere mich noch dass
im dezember 2001 der damalige
außenminister joschka fischer eine
konferenz mit allen vertretern
afghanistans in bonn auf dem petersberg
einberufen hat und damals den afghanen
auch ins gewissen geredet geredet hat
eine gemeinschaftliche lösung zu finden
und ich darf sagen in unserer
entwicklung
bemühungen wollten der afghanistan kein
system aufdrängen aber wir haben schon
erlebt dass sich millionen mädchen
gefreut haben in die schule zu gehen
dass frauen
mitbestimmen konnten und es gibt jetzt
auch viele in afghanistan die sehr sehr
unglücklich sind über die entwicklung
nichts desto trotz muss man da auch
sehen dass die taliban mehr
unterstützung bekommen haben als wir uns
das gewünscht hätten und jetzt muss man
versuchen mit ihnen zu reden und darauf
hinzuwirken dass die die in ihrem leben
bedroht sind und die für deutschland zum
beispiel gearbeitet haben das land
verlassen können und dass wir
bestimmte aktivitäten der
entwicklungszusammenarbeit auch
fortsetzen denn deutschland hat hier
sehr viel in der wasserversorgung in der
ex versorgung in der polio bekämpfung
gemacht es wäre sehr sehr traurig wenn
das dem afghanischen volk in zukunft
nicht wieder zu gute kommen könnte so
dass ich hoffe dass inklusive strukturen
gefunden werden können aus denen heraus
dann auch afghanistan für sich selbst
seinen weg befindet und sucht und wir
gleichzeitig den terrorismus nicht
wieder als eine internationale bedrohung
haben was rtr anbelangt so hat
deutschland das haben wir ihnen auch
schon des öfteren gesagt keinerlei druck
auf luxemburg ausgeübt und auch die
entscheidung über die zulassung in
deutschland wird unabhängig von der
regierung und von
schon ganz klar der bundesregierung aber
auch für die landesregierung geführt
dieser prozess ist ja für
begabt zdf
ob uns das an das münchner abkommen
besteht seit über sechs jahren trotzdem
ist die ukraine nach rebsorte teil
trotzdem sterben wie sie gerade selber
gesagt haben nach wie vor menschen
entlang der kontakt linie im don was
gibt es nach ihrem heutigen gespräch
konkrete pläne für einen neuen gipfel
aus zb staats und regierungschef und
chefinnen ebene oder muss man das
münster abkommen und ihre initiative
auch rund um das nochmal die verfahren
nicht als gescheitert erklären und herr
präsident
garantieren sie persönlich das auch nach
nach nach der fertigstellung von nord
stream 2 weiterhin gas durch die ukraine
geleitet wird und falls ja besteht diese
garantie auch über die kanzlerschaft von
frau angela merkel hinaus
also wir haben in dem bands gab kommen
noch nicht die ziele erreicht die wir
erreichen wollen aber es ist das
gesprächsformat was wir haben
inklusive der trilateralen kontaktgruppe
die dann ja auch die gespräche mit den
separatisten denn dort jetzt ganz führt
und damit
sollten wir mit diesem format pfleglich
umgehen so lange wir nichts anderes
haben aber der fortschritt ist nicht so
wie ich mir das wünschen würde wir haben
heute darüber gesprochen wenn man zu
einer tagesordnung kommt kann man auch
überlegen weitere hochrangige treffen
durchzuführen aber muss natürlich wissen
worüber wir sprechen und ich werde mich
auch bei meinem besuch in der ukraine
dafür einsetzen dass wir eine solche
tagesordnung zustande bringen denn jeder
kleine fortschritt könnte wichtig sein
aber das bett was wir zu bohren haben
ist sehr sehr dick und es gibt
enttäuschungen
verschiedenster art und trotzdem rate
ich dazu dieses format auch wenn es
länger dauert als wir uns das erhofft
haben weiter
sozusagen zu versuchen lebendig zu
gestalten und es nicht in einer
sackgasse enden zu lassen
kann ich der frau bundeskanzlerin und
nur beipflichten
was das nur man die format geht sowie
das minsker kommen wir haben tatsächlich
keine anderen gesprächs formate zur
verfügung deswegen sollten wir friedlich
und respektvoll damit umgehen ganz
ungeachtet dessen dass wir unsere ziele
bisher nicht erreichen konnten sind was
die beilegung der jeweiligen kurs legte
am genannt wir haben wie gesagt einer un
sicherheitsratsresolution
vorliegen
und somit haben
das minsker hat das minsker format nun
eine internationale grundlage was es
stärker macht
jedenfalls möchte ich betonen dass
natürlich auf internationaler ebene der
presse dass eine
gesagt wird national aber ganz andere
dinge besprochen werden und es gibt auch
seiten die die minsker abkommen die das
leider nicht einhalten
ich möchte noch einmal betonen dass die
ukraine einen neuen gesetzesentwurf
vorgelegt hat sollte dieser
gesetzesentwurf
erfüllt werden ich möchte sie dazu
aufrufen das zu lesen übrigens es ist
öffentlich zugänglich
und sollte dieser gesetzesentwurf
akzeptiert werden so würde die ukraine
das minsker abkommen verlassen es würde
austreten das würde also bedeuten noch
mal die ukraine fall lässt dieses
abkommen und ich hoffe sehr dass frau
bundeskanzlerin im rahmen ihres ukraine
besuch softer druck ausüben kann auf die
ukrainische führung damit dieses gesetz
nicht beschlossen wird was den
gas-transit anbelangt frau
bundeskanzlerin hat stets ihre position
vertreten immer sie ist nie abgewichen
das möchte ich gerne betonen wir haben
noch etwa 45 kilometer leitungen zu
verlegen
15.15 höre ich gerade auf dem
meeresgrund bleiben noch zu verlegen das
projekt ist also so gut wie
abgeschlossen frau bundeskanzlerin hat
stets diese frage stellte was den
transit über die ukraine anbelangt
ging auch im transit verträge und ich
möchte dazu folgendes sagen diese frage
haben wir heute natürlich erneut
besprochen
ich habe frau bundeskanzlerin
zugesichert dass er alle punkte
die im vertrag festgehalten werden
erfüllen werden auch wenn frau merkel
nicht mehr bundeskanzlerin ist und den
posten verlässt wir halten uns heute
daran und wir werden auch uns in zukunft
daran halten nur 10 2
es wurde hier angesprochen dass es ein
politischer prozess ist ich glaube das
ist nur eine verwirkung strategie es ist
alles andere als das gespräche von einer
bequemeren schnelleren sauberen gas
liefert es sind auch keine
leeren worte es ist eine viel
zukunftsträchtige technologie es ist
umweltfreundlicher gegönnt die co2
emissionen senken
unsere gaslieferung wird nachhaltiger
nach irgendwo und ich glaube dass wir
alle uns dessen bewusst sein müssen und
das wird außerdem wesentlich günstiger
sein als das tram der transit über die
ukrainische familie die uns derzeit zu
verstehen ich habe schon öffentlich
mehrfach beteuert und möchte es nun
betonen auch nach 20 24 sind wir bereit
gas über die ukraine zu leiten jedoch
sollten wir definieren in welchem
volumen und für wie lange dafür brauchen
wir aber eine antwort von unseren
europäischen partnern wie viel sie nun
bei uns einkaufen möchten ist das nicht
vollkommen offensichtlich
sie können doch keinen transit vertrag
unterzeichnen wo sehen hier keine
bestellungen vorliegen haben
und was die grüne politik angeht die
grüne agenda
die bereits umgesetzt mit in europa
haben wir folgende frage werdet ihr
überhaupt bei uns gas einkaufen oder
nicht und wenn ja wie viel das gilt es
also noch zu besprechen es ist also eine
rein kommerzielle frage es gibt auch
eine technische komponente
und ich möchte erneut betonen wir sind
nicht nur offen für gespräche dafür wir
sind auch bereit gewisse ziele
anzustreben
und auch in den süden gas zu liefern
denn die nachfrage steigt dort ich hoffe
dass wir zu bleiben in den kommenden
jahren denn
[Musik]
eine nachhaltigere quelle als das
russische gas für die energielieferungen
für deutschland für die europäischen
länder sehe ich nicht
vielen dank eine letzte frage bitte von
interfax
frau bundeskanzlerin sie haben sich über
16 jahre sehr häufig getroffen sie haben
stets telefoniert es gab
unterschiedliche augenblicke in diesem
deutsch russischen beziehungen insgesamt
wie bewerten sie die ergebnisse dieser
16 jahre wie sehen sie die zukunft der
bilateralen beziehungen vielen dank
es ist keine besonders korrekte
fragestellung muss ich sagen ich kann
natürlich nicht
für frau bundeskanzlerin antworten das
muss schon das deutsche volk tun es
steht eine wahl bevor da werden wir
sehen wie sich das entwickeln wird
die bundestagswahlen sind da
entscheidend was unsere beziehungen
angeht diese waren durchaus volatil
denn frau bundeskanzlerin hat betont
dass wir unterschiedliche
herangehensweisen haben zahlreiche
fragen zunächst desto trotz ist unser
das volumen unserer gemeinsamen
tätigkeiten beständig geblieben hat sich
sogar erweitert wir haben viel mehr
gemeinsame projekt es ist viel
umfassender geworden besprachen heute
über die wirtschaft
und wie gesagt deutschland ist der
zweitwichtigste handelspartner nach
china
für uns siebeneinhalb milliarden dollar
beträgt
das handelsvolumen wir haben
sehr viel investiert etwa siebeneinhalb
milliarden dollar wie gesagt oder
neuneinhalb waren es sogar haben wir in
deutschland investiert und 18 milliarden
haben wiederum unsere deutschen partner
investiert deutsche unternehmen arbeiten
hauptsächlich
im industriebereich in der produktion
und wir schätzen das sehr
wir haben heute auch einige sehr
konkrete fragen besprochen in diesem
bereich
denn natürlich möchten wir auch
weiterhin deutsche geschäfte umsetzen
und fördern in russland das und eines
laufende fragen insgesamt jedoch lässt
sich sagen dass die qualität und das
volumen unserer bilateralen beziehungen
sich zum besseren gewandelt haben in den
vergangenen jahren und ich möchte meine
hoffnung aus sprechen dafür dass diese
tendenz auch weiterhin steigt auch nach
den bundestagswahlen
ich bin zutiefst davon überzeugt dass
auch bei
unterschiedlichen politischen systemen
die
gesprächskanäle offen gehalten werden
müssen und dass wir uns austauschen
müssen das zeigt die gesamte lage der
welt das zeigen aber auch unsere
geschichtlichen beziehungen zwischen
deutschland und russland die sehr
vielgestaltig mit den schlimmsten tiefen
und guten zeiten war insgesamt muss ich
sagen meine amtszeit haben sich
sicherlich die politischen systeme von
deutschland und russland noch einmal
weiter auseinander entwickelt das heißt
dass wir auch viele kritische fragen
miteinander zu besprechen haben aber ich
bin sehr froh dass es trotz großer
differenzen immer gelungen ist diesen
gesprächskanäle offen zu halten uns
manchmal haben wir dabei auch glaube ich
ein bisschen etwas bewegen können aber
es bleibt sehr viel zu tun aber ich
werde immer dafür werben dass das nicht
sprechen keine option aus meiner sicht
ist
ein schuss passieren dass
ich zu den danken